Manor on the contrary is not an existent
thing but as being in the form of the
universal or in the form of a notion
reason which is still instinctive makes
this correct distinction without being
aware that just by testing the law on
all sensuous being it gets rid of the
merely sensuous being of the law and
when it interprets the moments of the
law as matters they're essential nature
has become for reason a universal and as
such as expressed as a non sensuous
thing of sense as an incorporeal and yet
objective being
in paragraph 252 hingle is continuing
his investigation from a
phenomenological perspective of what it
is that goes on when we observe nature
and arrive at laws which then we attempt
to apply to nature and there's an
ongoing dialectical process between
observing and forming laws and then
seeing how those laws pan out and then
seeing how they change in the process he
introduced this term matter or not to be
in in the previous paragraph saying that
the sensuous things that we are applying
the law to are really you might say
placeholders or appearances or in the
way of the the the matters that were
we're really trying to study we'll try
to get to the essence of things when
we're working with one so he tells us
more about this saying matter is not an
existent thing thing there's just ding
right so anything that can be a thing
for us an object in any sense that it's
not an existent thing that doesn't mean
that it doesn't have being sign but it
has being in a different way than say a
thing like this a piece of chalk so what
what is it that and notice I underlined
that is what is this this kind of manner
that we're talking about so he goes on
he tells us that what reason in its
instinctual activity is able to realize
it to differentiate it is between what
the matter is
and what the sensuous things that are
being studied through through the the
use of a walk these matters like for
example you know bass and acid or
positive and negative electricity are
being and here the translation
a little bit misleading because it uses
the same formulation he says this is
Miller's translation being in the form
of a universal or in the form of a
notion it's actually being as a
universal alt argument right yeah that
in the form of a notion of it great so
what's going on there we hope to be so
worried about the lexical
differentiation we want to see what
we're differentiating these against and
that is the sensuous being to which the
in a law is being applied and from which
we presume the law is being made to
emerge and this process is not entirely
clear at this point so he goes on and he
says reason is not aware that just by
testing the law and all centers being
what it does is in a certain way
purifies the law what does he purify it
what does it purify the law that
sensuous aspect it turns the law into
something that although it does apply to
sensuous particulars is not itself a
sensuous particular it's something that
has a different metaphysical status we
could say so he goes I don't he says
when it interprets the moments of the
law as matters they're essential nature
has become for reason the universal
right yeah and here's a wonderful phrase
it is expressed as a non sensuous thing
of sense now what does that mean a non
sensuous thing of sense so we don't have
the universal as something that's
totally detached from sense what we have
is the universal which is being
developed into a concept or notion and
something that you might say straddles
the entire sensuous world to witches
it's to apply and permeates in a certain
way that sensuous world which shows us
that there is more
than just that sensuous world that what
we might call a vulgar mechanistic
materialistic attitude about the the
observable world is a rather restrictive
way of looking at so what we're going to
see come out of this is what else is
involved and so he's setting the stage
for that right here
we have now to see what turn its result
takes for it and what new shape it's
observational activity assumes in
consequence we find as the truth of this
experiment in consciousness pure law
which is freed from sensuous being we
see it as an ocean which while present
in sensuous being operates there
independently and unrestrained and while
immersed in it is free of it in a simple
notion this which is in truth the result
an essence of it of its activity is now
present to this consciousness itself but
as an object further since for it the
object is not a result and is not
connected with the preceding activity it
presents itself to consciousness as a
particular kind of object and the
relation of consciousness to it appears
is another kind of observation
in paragraph 253 Hegel is talking about
observation taking on a new shape or
Gestalt and he wants to lead us into the
activity as phenomenologist
of observing the development of
consciousness in reason figuring out
what is that new shape so what I've got
laid out of here on the board is pretty
straightforward it follows along with
this passage he talks about this
experimenting or you know seeking
consciousness right
grasping now then it's got a purely law
or present to it in the form of a notion
that which is essential we've seen that
this can be connected to but also at the
same time is independent of sensuous
being notice I put this in plural here
because what we're talking about is an
entire range of sensuous beings that are
concrete particulars and the law itself
is supposed to be a universal which
governs all of these particulars a
universal in a different way than say
the universal corresponding to these
particulars if we're talking about
marbles right and then we talk about
marble capital and the Platonic form or
whatever we want the universal law is a
bit more complicated than that
now Hegel said is that this right here
is a result we use uses that word or
absence of eizan but that consciousness
is not going to grasp it as a result or
essence rather consciousness is going to
grasp the law as an object again found
for consciousness and he says that this
produces a new observation the way the
Miller has it here the text is present
to consciousness as a particular kind of
object and the relation of consciousness
to it appear
as another kind of observation so what's
happening here is that a consciousness
in its process of trying to work out
laws stripping them away while not
actually breaking the connection between
the laws and the empirical realities in
which the consciousness by aided by the
way it also exists is making the law
itself into a particular kind of object
for it which then it can continue to
stop
such an object in which the process is
present in the simplicity of the notion
is the organism it is this absolute
fluidity in which the determinant nests
through which it would only be for
another is dissolved the inorganic thing
has determinate Nisour its essential
nature and for that reason constitutes
the moments of the notion in their
completeness only together with another
thing and therefore is lost when it
enters into the process in the organic
being on the contrary every determinate
nest which it is open to another is
controlled by the organic simple unity
none of them shows itself as essential
as free to enter into relation with
another and consequently what is organic
maintains itself in its relation
you might have at this point be
wondering where all of this discussion
about the nature of law as concept or
notion of a crib and observing
consciousness where is all this going
well in paragraph 254 Hegel is going to
make an important turn that shows us
what he's really after in this
discussion again I don't know whether
you could say that the sort of inherent
necessity of it is is being actively
demonstrated I think that in some
respects this is a complete aside he
could be expressing himself a bit more
clearly at this point but but but he
seems to you know feel or think or judge
that the motive presentation that he's
providing us here is what we need to be
following along in order to see why
things turned out the way they are now
notice that what we've gotten here on
the board and what's corresponding this
passage is a distinction between an
inorganic thing and an organism which we
should also say an organism is also a
thing right but it's a different kind of
thing than Thinley things than things
that are just inorganic and what he's
going to call our attention to here by
talking in terms of fluidity and
determination as opposed to mere
determinate Ness is the fact that the
organic thing that of the organism that
we're trying to observe and formulate
laws about has a way of resisting our
capacity to generalize to conceptualize
about it and the further that it's
removed from the merely inorganic the
more complex this gets this is
foreshadowing of course where we're
going to be looking at the human
organism the creature that is involved
in this entire
process of observation and I want to get
too far ahead of us let's look at what
what he says here in us this pianist has
many says such an object writing this
particular kind of object is present and
the simplicity the notion is the
organism yeah it's an absolute fluidity
we see this in his discussion of life in
which the determinant nests through
which it would be only for another is
dissolved there's a kind of controlling
of the relationship between the other
and the self that occurs with organic
beings that does not occur with
inorganic things which you don't react
with each other chemically or physically
or whatever we want to say but don't end
up controlling what's what's going on
and so as Hegel is going to say the
inorganic thing has to determine it as
for its essential nature and it is what
it is for that reason constitutes the
moments of the notion and their
completeness only together with an other
thing right
so you know for example acid-base right
positive negative electricity these are
not organic things at this point
sure and whatever other things we want
to connect it with he goes on he says
then they're lost when they enter into
the process now does that mean that
they're actually they vanish off the
scene we don't know we're talking about
no but there's a lack of essentiality to
them that is present there in organic
being how so well that is part of what
we're going to have to unpack in them in
a following paragraphs but he says here
with the organic being every determinate
that's through which it's open to an
other it's only determining this is
controlled by the organic simple unity
so it is connected with the monitor with
altera T but in a certain way it
controls that relation
with its other and that's why I can take
in its its other in a way that this this
can and can you know react to new
circumstances so he says what's organic
maintains itself in this relation with
the other it doesn't vanish it doesn't
you know shuffle off the scene it
remains more essential we could say in
Hegel's language
the aspects of law which the instinct of
reason here proceeds to observe are as
follows from the above characterization
in the first instance organic nature and
inorganic nature in their relation to
one another
the latter is for organic nature no more
than the freedom the freedom opposed to
the simple notion of organic nature of
the loosely connected to terminus is in
which the individual forms of nature are
dissolved and which at the same time
breaking away from their continuity
exist on their own account air water
earth zones and climate are universal
elements of this sort which constitute
the indeterminate simple essence of
natural individuality and in which these
are at the same time reflected into
themselves neither the individuality nor
the universal element is absolutely in
and for itself
on the contrary though they appear to
observation as free and independent they
behave at the same time as essentially
connected but in such a way that their
independence and mutual indifference are
the predominant feature and only in part
become abstractions here then we have
law as the connection of a universal
element with a formative process of the
organism which on the other hand has the
elementary being over against it and on
the other hand exhibits it with within
its organic reflection but laws of this
kind animals belonging to the ear have
the nature of birds those belonging to
water of the nature of fish animals at
northern latitudes have thick hairy
palates and so on such laws are seen at
a glance to display a poverty which does
not do justice to the manifold variety
of organic nature besides the fact that
organic nature and its freedom can
divest its forms of these
characteristics and of necessity
everywhere presents exceptions to such
laws or rules as we might call them the
characterization of the creatures to
which they do apply is so superficial
that even the necessity of the laws
cannot be other than superficial and
amounts to no more than the great
influence of environment and this does
not tell us what what does and what does
not strictly belong to this influence
such relations of organisms to the
elements they live in cannot therefore
in fact be called laws for firstly the
content of such a relation as we saw
does not exhaust the range of the
organisms concerned and secondly the the
size of the relation itself are mutually
indifferent and expressed no necessity
in the notion of acid lies the notion of
base just as the notion of positive
electricity implies that have negative
but often as we may find a thick hairy
Pelt associated with northern latitudes
or the structure of a fish associated
with water or that of birds with air the
notion of north does not imply the
notion of a thick tarry Pelt the notion
of sea does not imply the notion of the
structure of fish or the notion of air
that of the structure of birds because
of the freedom of the two sides in
relation to each other there are also
land animals which have the essential
characteristics of a bird of a fish and
so on the necessity just because it
cannot be grasped as an inner necessity
of the creature ceases to have a
sensuous existence and can no longer be
observed in the world of reality but has
withdrawn from it
finding thus no place in the actual
creature it is what is called the
teleological relation a relation which
is external to the related terms and
therefore really the antithesis of the
law it is a conception completely freed
from the necessity of a nature a
conception which leaves that necessity
behind and operates Ponty spontaneously
above it
we're going to begin this long paragraph
number 255 by talking about law and
ultimately we're going to end up
introducing a concept of teleological
relation which angle is going to say is
opposed to that of law opposed in part
because the necessity that it imposes is
a necessity that stems from a greater
freedom so that's going to be a key idea
here let's see how that actually plays
out you notice that I've got organic
nature inorganic nature being contrasted
to each other here so he says these are
these aspects of law and we're talking
about voila here we don't just mean you
know very universal laws like gravity
we're talking about observing
consciousness attempting to expand its
storehouse of information of knowledge
by observing things in the world things
that it runs across and trying to go
into their specificity trying to
generalize from that basis trying to
come up with law like regularities that
it says that it can observe in nature so
how does this panned out he says in the
first instance we have organic nature
and inorganic nature in their relation
to one another what do we mean by them
well organic nature would be say
everything from I suppose it depends on
you know exactly how you want to qualify
or classify viruses I would say that
they're they're organic everything from
viruses all the way on up to you know
human beings gigantic fungoid colonies
ant hills everything that you want
plants you know one celled organisms all
of those are organic nature all of them
involve certain base
functions that we're going to see talked
about it in later paragraphs now they
exist in relation to a wider environment
of inorganic nature right of which some
parts might in fact be organic you know
if we talk about it's actually herbs for
example so if we're thinking in terms of
you know just pure minerals okay that's
not organic but if we think in terms of
soil okay that is something that has
some organic qualities or components to
it and then in case he says the latter
that means this relation for organic
nature no more than the freedom a
freedom opposed to the simple notion of
organic nature the loosely connected
determinant this is in which individual
forms of nature are dissolved in which
at the same time breaking away from
their continuity exist on their own
account what does what does all that
mean well he's talking about a inorganic
nature as we've observed as we as we've
seen observing reason observe there are
things of certain classes things of you
know what we might call repeatable
determinate neces and these are loosely
connected with each other but we can't
come up with laws about them you know we
can say things that are meaningful about
ear or water or you know soil or
minerals or the way you know which the
the zones of the world are sent out it's
you know in terms of latitude longitude
climate all these sorts of things we can
indeed talk about meaningfully and we
can observe as human beings have been
doing this for a very long time so he
says these constitutes the the
determinant is that we're looking at air
or water earth these are indeterminate
simple essence of natural individuality
which are reflected into themselves
there's the you know Hegel's philosophy
of nature I wouldn't worry too much
about that
because the the real show here is on the
other side when we're dealing with
organic nature now the organic nature
behaves the way that it does you know we
can we can come up with Sciences like
physics in chemistry and even you know
meteorology they have geology things
like that to sort of sort of explain
what's going on with these things that
we observe organic nature now that we're
venturing over into biology right and
some of the other ones later on as we
get to more and more complex things
that's not quite so straightforward as
this is so he says here we go
neither the individuality nor the
universal element is absolutely before
itself they they appear to observation
of screen and pen and we're talking
about the energy act they behave as
essentially connected but what's going
on there is there's a renewal
indifference to each other they exist
for consciousness what about the organic
being he says here we have law as the
connection of the universal element of
the formative process of the organism
which on the one hand has the elementary
being over here over against it and on
the other hand exhibits it within its
organic reflection what is he talking
about there by talking about organic
reflection the organic being works upon
its environment its world on other word
Jannik beings but also on the non
organic and takes it in reacts to it
modifies it consumes it excretes it does
all these sorts of things that can't
happen on their own just by inorganic
nature with it's very interesting and
complex processes but organic nature
brings a kind of reflectiveness
it kind of in
tensity two things that we're going to
see Hangul exploring in the passages of
the paragraphs yet to come
so what's the upshot for law here's
where it gets really interesting as far
as the discussion of water goes so he
says there's that there's a temptation
to make all sorts of generalizations
that we want to call laws about an
organic nature what are the examples
that he uses animals in the area have
the characteristics of birds and you
know that kind of makes sense right what
are what are birds characteristics and
maybe they have wings right so in a
sense that fly you have K they're
different birds if we had flying
servants presumably they have to have
wings right and we can go on and further
and further the animals and the water
have the characteristics of fish what
are the characteristics of fish well
they they breathe water and they have
fins and we can go further and further
right here's another great one animals
in northern latitudes and he means by
this really far northern latitudes have
thick hairy pelts think about beavers
and bears and caribou and whatever I'll
say you like so does this work and says
these laws display a poverty that
doesn't do justice to the manifold
variety of organic nature these laws
don't turn out to really be laws in any
full sense why he says it's clear that
in organic nature and here we're talking
about these these you know basic large
scale things does in fact have an
environmental effect in conditioning
what happens with organic nature but on
the side of organic nature there is an
incredible determinate freedom a
capacity to you know shift around
whatever conditions this is imposing
upon and to that Hegel hasn't even gone
this far yeah that organic nature is not
only you might say locked in a relation
all struggle with inorganic nature but
with other organic nature itself within
its own species in relation to other
species of manifold different types so
he says organic nature everywhere
presents exceptions to such laws or
rules we might call them the
characterization of the creatures to
which they apply is so superficial that
even the necessity of the laws must be
superficial and if we call them the
Cecily superficial it's not really
necessity and also he says these
relations are the elements of the
organism to the elements they live in
cannot be called laws why the content of
such a relation is not exhaust the range
of the organisms involved so you can
have organisms that do seem to follow
into these laws but you also have
organisms that somehow escape those laws
so they're not really laws and the
environment doesn't really fully
determine the organic creature then he
goes on and he says the signs of the
relation itself were mutually
indifferent and expressed no necessity
this is another sort of more
metaphysical point he says in the notion
of base there is contained the notion of
acid and reciprocally right so there
there's a mutual implication there
positive and negative electricity to all
that's over here on the side of the
inorganic nature by the way even though
you know organic nature might have the
acids and bases so make acid things that
nature but there is no sort of necessary
mutual implication there for example
with northern climates that doesn't
necessarily have to produce hairy thick
pelts and you can find other animals
with hairy thick pelts in conditions
elsewhere y kyc says you know birds with
ear you know you you can in fact find
birds flying around in here but the
notion of air does not
why the structure of birds by itself
there's many other possibilities so he
says because of the freedom of the two
sides have in relation to each other
there's also Leon the animals which have
these essential characteristics of a
bird of a fish and so on and then he
says the necessity because it cannot be
grasped as an inner necessity of the
creature on this side ceases to have a
sensuous existence and it can't be
observed in the world of reality but is
withdrawn so these these laws are things
that could exist you had say a textbook
but then when you could try to go apply
the textbook to reality you find out
reality is a hell of a lot more
complicated than the textbook and here
you're understandably upset that the
textbook doesn't seem to apply quite as
well I mean you're probably one possible
thing is kill under the animal that
doesn't fit the textbook definitions
well that would be an interminable test
or use you know blinders off and pretend
that that you know you can't see those
animals but then you're disconnecting
yourself from the reality that you want
it to understand reason doesn't do that
reason has a desire to know and so when
reason runs into an obstacle like this
it's gonna have to somehow figure out
how to surmount that obstacle
what is going to surmount that was where
Hegel is going to turn to what he's
calling a teleological relation so he
goes ahead and he says finding the snow
place in the actual creature the
necessity it is what is called a
teleological relation a relation which
is external to the related terms and is
really the antithesis of a law what is
he to anything about there okay so a
teleological relation is a relation to
some sort of Telos some sort of end some
sort of process of unfolding of
developing of you know reaching a
destination a point you can say although
sometimes the tools can be simply just
to continue things on as they are so if
this necessity is not going to be found
in
the inorganic nature and its
relationship to the organic being the
the creature the organism we're going to
have to look for this relationship
elsewhere and he says it's a conception
completely free from the necessity of
nature a conception which leaves that
necessity behind it operates
spontaneously above it now that seems to
throw a big monkey wrench into any
notion of law
Hegel's goal as we're going to see him
moving into the next paragraphs is to
expand the conception of law so that it
can actually take into account teleology
and that's you know quite a project to
to embark upon it's going to end up
requiring us to rethink the ways in
which we typically frame for ourselves
all of this